this year single stay kicked off with a
colorful gala complete with excited fans
customers and a live tally of incoming
sales the 1 billion dollar mark fell
after a mere 85 seconds after an hour
sales had reached 10 billion dollars by
the end of the day revenue it online
giant Alibaba clocked in at thirty point
eight billion dollars a new record the
singles day shopping festival has
reached its 10th year it means not only
discounts but also appreciation I want
sellers to show their gratitude to
consumers by offering them the best
products and the best prices
among the sellers were many global
players all in all some hundred and
eighty thousand brands participated in
the consumer frenzy Alibaba hopes even
more companies will begin participating
bringing even higher revenues I'll be
honest I've been wondering about the
future of singles day many people have
been asking me about this to singles day
look set to achieve revenues of 200
billion yuan and we'll make changes as
we go along I think we can bring it to
300 billions 500 billion maybe even a
trillion the sky's the limit though at
the moment feet should remain firmly on
the ground with a general slowdown in
the Chinese economy revenue growth has
slowed from 40 percent last year to 27
percent this year